[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 nous sommes le mardi
5 octobre voici les titres de cette
édition le tribunal judiciaire de
versailles accueillir la nuit du droit
en événement national organisé également
dans les yvelines par l'université
versailles saint quentin conférences
échanges se sont succédé autour de la
figure du philosophe du 19e siècle
alexis de tocqueville une pandémie de
confinement et une crise des matières
premières le monde du bâtiment était
largement impacter sur ces derniers mois
comment se porte le secteur en ce début
d'automne dans le département nous
poserons la question à christophe
bourquin président de la fédération
française du bâtiment des yvelines
et puis rencontre avec georges cette
ville noire de quatre ans est passionné
de golf et le pratiquent déjà sur les
greens c'est son père qui lui a transmis
la fièvre de la petite balle blanche qui
vient taper tous les dimanches à plaisir
son portrait
la campagne électorale qui se poursuit à
trappes en vue du premier tour de
l'élection municipale partielle c'est ce
dimanche focus ce soir sur la
candidature de patrick plan pour lutte
ouvrière la suite aussi de notre dossier
de la rédaction consacré cette semaine
aux plans en france relance dans les
yvelines
[Musique]
sensibiliser le grand public au droit
faire connaître ses institutions et ses
métiers tous les 4 octobre la nuit du
droit se fixent cet objectif en sept
jours cette journée anniversaire de la
constitution de 1958 dans les yvelines
le rendez vous se tenait hier au
tribunal judiciaire de versailles le
thème cette année alexis de tocqueville
et précision dans ce sujet de céline
charles et de nicolas landry
cette année alexis de tocqueville s'est
invitée à la fête du droit au tribunal
de versailles il y à presque 200 ans ce
célèbre philosophe et homme politique du
19e siècle connu pour ses écrits sur la
démocratie avait exercé en ces lieux
tocqueville à exercer dans ce tribunal
au début de sa carrière dans les années
1800 27 à 1832 comme auditeur de justice
c'est à dire comme juge stagiaires idées
simples comme
on a la fête de la science est bien
c'est de faire connaître ce droit aux
usages et aux non juristes pour cette
nouvelle édition l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines a
décidé de mettre à l'honneur la question
de la démocratie
professionnels du droit et étudiants ont
pu confronter leurs agit à travers des
lectures des conférences et des débats
je crois que le plus important de ce que
nous y tocqueville sur ce qui se passe
dans le monde contemporain c'est qu'ils
nous mettent en garde contre les dangers
d'une tyrannie de la majorité ma
déclamation portent essentiellement sur
la nécessité de contre-pouvoir efficace
dans une démocratie elle est fragilisée
pour deux raisons la première c'est une
traverse un climat de crise avec un
contexte est difficile et la deuxième
chose c'est que il ya un climat de
défiance envers les représentants
ouvert à tous lavit eu droit à plusieurs
objectifs c'est montrer nos citoyens
concitoyens l'importance du droit dans
la régulation de la société ce qu'on
peut en attendant termes de droits mais
aussi des devoirs ce que nous cherchons
à faire ici à la faculté de droit et à
travers ce type d'événement c'est bien
sûr de montrer à nos étudiants qu'il
faut absolument continuer de s'ouvrir
sur le monde actuel sur l'histoire le
rendez vous est déjà pris en 2022 pour
célébrer les soixante quatre ans de la
constitution de la vème république
nouvelle occasion de rappeler au plus
grand nombre que le droit aussi a droit
à sa soirée
à l'hommage hier à stéphanie mon fermer
le 23 avril le dernier set policière
était assassiné par un terroriste devant
le commissariat de rambouillet en sa
mémoire ce lundi une plaque
commémorative a été apposée sur place
une cérémonie dans la plus stricte
intimité en présence notamment de la
ministre déléguée à la citoyenneté
marlène schiappa un jardin du souvenir a
été également aménagés dans l'enceinte
du commissariat la mobilisation des
habitants de magnan really hier lundi il
était à des centaines à venir acclamer
leur opposition au projet de prison
annoncé par le ministre le ministre de
la justice une maison d'arrêt de 700
places doit être construit d'ici 2027
sur un terrain agricole de la commune ce
qui a suscité une vive désapprobation
parmi les magnans vie loi qui se sont
rassemblés juste avant conseil municipal
cible des attaques le maire de la
commune michel debout qui a même reçu
une délégation d'habitants quelques
minutes plus tard pendant la séance de
conseil municipal est les élus ont voté
une motion contre le projet affaire à
suivre attrape l'élection partielle
municipales partielles se déroule ce
dimanche premier tour et qui est donc au
programme ce dimanche un deuxième tour
au programme le dimanche d'après et
parmi les quatre candidats en lice pour
devenir maire patrick planque pour sa
liste lutte ouvrière il compte une
nouvelle fois faire entendre la voix des
travailleurs durant la campagne le
reportage de ces dégâts tsongo faire
entendre le camp des travailleurs c'est
le slogan du parti lutte ouvrière mais
aussi le but de leur combat attrape une
liste l eau est conduite par patrick
planque un ouvrier de maintenance
ferroviaire on a rencontré des
travailleurs un peu partout sur les
marchés dans les entreprises dans les
quartiers où on est allé prospecter on
est allé faire du porte à porte il ya
une vraie inquiétude de la part des
salariés et à une vraie inquiétude de la
part des travailleurs sur la situation
et le fait qu'ils aient une liste dans
ces élections qui défendent un point de
vue ouvriers un point de vue de
travailleurs lutte de classes qui ont
envie de se bagarrer et bien ça va
changer un peu les choses une réunion
publique avait lieu vendredi 1er octobre
à la maison des familles objectif
présenter la liste et les grandes idées
c'est ça notre programme c'est un
programme de lutte c'est pas un
programme avec des promesses électorales
en disant voté pour nous et on va
changer les choses non c'est un
programme pour dire oui il faut que les
travailleurs s'organisent ils se
défendent ils se préparent à une bagarre
offensive contre les contre le patronat
contre le gouvernement quelques
sympathisants militants ou candidat sur
la liste ont débattu des problèmes liés
à trappes et plus généralement en france
changer les les toute la structure de
des avantages qu'il ya certaines
personnes que je trouve très très
difficile à tenir avec les budgets
qu'ils ont dans cette mairie je
travaille je suis une salariée comme
tous les salariés on a besoin de
défendre des salariés s'étaient
nous-mêmes bah oui quand même quoi je
vais dire si on les défend pas qui va
les défendre c'est pas le gouvernement
qui va les défendre
oui les élections municipales partielles
de trappes se dérouleront les 10 et 17
octobre prochains
dans l'actualité également ce triste
constat l'ile-de-france est la région de
l'hexagone où il ya eu le plus de
signalement pour violences sexuelles et
sexistes en 2021 révélations de sandrine
maçon à nos confrères du parisien elle
dirige le portail nationale de
signalement de violence sexuelle et
sexiste
une structure qui fonctionne 7 jours sur
7 24 heures sur 24 et qui est installée
à guyancourt depuis novembre 2010 8 /
7129 signalements effectués entre
janvier et juillet dernier
2294 concerne l ile de france la plupart
provenant du département des
hauts-de-seine suivi par la seine saint
denis
[Musique]
et dans ce journal on parle à présent
d'une autre actualité le bâtiment qui a
fait face ces derniers mois une pandémie
de confinement est également une crise
des matières premières les pois en
parler avec moi sur ce plateau
christophe bouquin bonjour bonsoir vous
êtes le président de la fédération
française du bâtiment dans les épinards
on va commencer cet entretien avec le
chic on va parler de cette crise des
matières premières qui affecte forcément
encore votre secteur en ce moment mais
la capeb qui est le syndicat patronal de
l'artisanat du bâtiment indiqué qu' il y
avait plus 37% de l'activité dans le
bâtiment premier semestre 2021 par
rapport à l'année passée une année qui
avait été déjà largement impacté par la
crise sanitaire est ce que les carnets
en ce début de deuxième semaine 2021 est
ce que les carnets de commandes sont
pleins voyez tout à fait on a la chance
d'avoir des carnets de commandes qui
sont bien remplies c'est pas tellement
le
le problème en fait le problème bas
comme on est des on s'est déjà dit tous
les deux c'est que il nous manque de la
matière première et en plus une hausse
sur les prix de cette matière première
oui vous disions c'est effectivement
parlé on s'est rencontré au cours de cet
entretien d'un entretien dans le journal
en avril dernier finalement il ya un
paradoxe c'est à dire que les carnets de
commande aujourd'hui son plein mais ses
commandes vous le dites ne peuvent pas
être honorée en aura exactement
aujourd'hui on a des ruptures sur sur
plein de matériaux les matériaux
arrivent au compte-gouttes vous pouvez
pas avoir une commande qui est qui est
passé vous aurez pas l'intégralité de
votre commande elle va être dispatchés
un petit peu à tout le monde
voilà c'est très problématique
aujourd'hui vous avez des salariés qui
sont là vous avez des salariés avec
lequel vous aimeriez bien les lancer sur
les chantiers et malheureusement tous
tout en découle il y en a un qui peut
pas poser sur les gros chantiers bas
vous avez ça qui arrive c'est que tout
le monde est décalé
c'est une problématique la deuxième
romantique problématique c'est le prix
est vivant et autant pour les grosses
entreprises que pour l'artisan l'artisan
à lui le problème de l'approvisionnement
aussi et du cou et lui avec une très
très grande difficulté de le reporter
sur son client final qui a signé un
devis à un moment donné et voilà ça
c'est c'est le lot quotidien de
l'entrepreneur et de l'artisan
aujourd'hui temps-ci autre paradoxe il
ya bien des salariés pour pour ces
chantiers mais c'est toujours le
problème des matières premières alors
les salariés on a embauché énormément
puisque le bâtiment ses soixante dix
mille emplois voilà effectivement le
gros problème c'est les matières
premières ont dit ses impressions adage
qui dit quand le bâtiment va tout va est
effectivement france cette situation de
pénurie des matières premières aussi
inquiète on a vu aussi des hausses dans
les supermarchés qui impacte directement
les consommateurs et en avril dernier
vous établissez une situation
inquiétante 1 pour le pvc l'aluminium le
verre le bois qui avait connu une
flambée des prix à l'époque plus de 100
% la situation a empiré vous le dit
aujourd'hui bah alors empirer de le 200%
on est stabilisé là dessus c'est vrai
mais aujourd'hui c'est plus tellement le
prix le problème c'est enfin le prix
d'un problème et le problème c'est qu'en
plus il ya un manque c'est à dire que
certains mettaient eux sont devenus
carrément des produits de précieux très
exactement nous sur des produits de base
je vous disais que on est sûr de cette
semaine courant habituel on est passé à
14 semaines et 14 semaines qui ne sont
même pas garantie c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui le fabricant vous dit pas
avant pas avant quatorze semaines et
vous n'êtes même pas certain que ce sera
peut-être quinze ou seize semaines
aujourd'hui ça cg1 pour un client final
c'est compliqué pour un planning c'est
compliqué tout tout tout tout ce qu'il
ya eu avant était compliqué à mettre en
place les gestes barrières les danses
une difficulté supplémentaire vous le
dites les gestes barrière la mise en
place de masquer sa déjà été un coup
supplémentaire c'était un peu près 3%
effectivement qui a été
impacté sur les devis pareil à l'époque
toujours pas révisable aujourd'hui on a
quand même bien mise en place tout le
monde autant nos salariés nous mêmes on
a mis ça en place on appuie kloster on a
en a rien eu on est plutôt fier de ça et
aujourd'hui effectivement on est
impactée même pas par le manque de
travail mais par le manque de cette
matière première les produits les plus
en tension c'est ce que j'en cite épais
dossier on voit là l'aluminium le pvc le
l'acier tout tout tout notre quotidien
est impacté par ça et ça se ressent
directement sur les marges puisque quand
les deux vies ont été scellées le prix
des matières premières et était
différent il a il a augmenté depuis
exactement alors il ya quelques accords
qui sont trouvées pour des grands
groupes est effectivement voilà mais
pour tout ce qui est le quotidien de
l'artisan par exemple c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très impactant pour lui
au quotidien seulement et le petit
artisan lui même s'il lui manque un
lavabo il peut pas aller chez son client
il faut hélas les chaudières aujourd'hui
il ya plus de choses nouvelles qui sont
sur le marché il ya plus de pièces pour
réparer alors qu'on arrive au début de
l'hiver les c'est souvent à ce moment là
que les jours dit on entend bien en
panne les cartes électroniques sont sont
plus contention on annonce des quatre
cinq six semaines de délai voilà ça
c'est la grosse inquiétude pour nos
clients que nous essayons de dépanner au
quotidien dans une situation où il dit
avec des retards 14 semaines qui peuvent
être augmentés ce qu'il ya des chantiers
aussi totalement à l'arrêt aujourd'hui à
cause de cette pénurie il y en a
aujourd'hui c'est pas encore le gros
chiffres mais je il y en a il y en a
effectivement qui sont bloqués je vous
dis par uniquement un corps de métier
qui peut être impacté mais qui va
retarder tout l'enclenchement de du
champion générale en avril dernier vous
demandiez le gel des pénalités de retard
est ce que vous avez été entendu sur ce
point là pour le gouvernement il ya eu
des progrès il ya eu il ya eu des
progrès par contre ces pénalités de
retard beau jeu ça ça a été entendu pour
connaître c'est quand même des choses
qui sont qui ont été mises en place pas
pour tous les marchés mais il ya eu
quand même des choses qui aujourd'hui
sont pris en compte au fur et à mesure
que la crise continue et
et qu'ils sont mais en application avec
peut-être plus de facilité le disiez
tout à l'heure avant cet entretien dans
les marchés publics sur les marchés
privés et privés etc voilà aujourd'hui
l'artisan on essaye de l'en de
l'entourer de l'accompagner par des
services et plein de conseils mais c'est
vrai que lui sur un client final il a
aucun pouvoir sur un deuil à un prix
aujourd'hui nous on a des plis chez nos
professionnels qui sont de données pour
deux ou trois jours c'est à dire que
vous quand vous avez un devis qui
arrivent il développe trois jours donc
votre client imaginez-vous que il vous
donne pas la réponse au bout de trois
jours et deux semaines trois semaines
après l'apport et bien vous avez déjà
subi une hausse supérieure question
christophe google président de la ffb au
niveau national demandait que
effectivement dans cette situation
difficile pour le monde du bâtiment soit
pris en considération dans le projet de
loi finances qui se prépare il a demandé
des mesures exceptionnelles aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous demandez concrètement
puisqu'il ya des demandes spécifiques
alors haut niveau au niveau national et
vais effectivement je pense que vous
venez dire cesser ce retour à la
discussion sur les pénalités de retard
ce cette écoute sur pouvoir renégocier
une fois que les marchés sont
accepter mais avec des taux c'est
vraiment les choses principales qui nous
sont aujourd'hui vital pour prendre aux
entreprises l'état d'esprit aujourd'hui
n'est pas forcément au beau fixe vous
êtes quand même vous avez un espoir
quand même ça s'arrange franchement leur
l'entrepreneur en lui-même il est
forcément beau fixe en permanence et
tous les matins il a des problèmes ni
les résout c'est son lot quotidien donc
on va pas vous dire on par rapport à
d'autres secteurs d'activité on n'a pas
trop le droit on a de la chance d'avoir
tout ça on est inquiet on est préoccupés
mais on a on a encore la patate et pas
de souci merci avec les saoudiens d'être
venu en parler en plateau et je rappelle
que vous êtes le président de la
fédération française du bâtiment dans
les yvelines merci d'avoir été avec no
mercy ou
[Musique]
la suite à présent de notre dossier de
la rédaction toute cette semaine tv 78
s'intéresse au déploiement du plan en
france relance dans les yvelines focus
ce soir sur la société est belle baie
belbeoch à l'e-mail est située à limay
spécialisé dans l'industrie arboricole
cette entreprise a bénéficié d'une
subvention de cinq cent soixante quinze
mille euros dans le cadre du plan de
relance l'objectif avec cette aide
développer son activité au travers de
l'acquisition d'un nouveau terrain
nicolas d'ombré
l'élagage et l'abattage des arbres pour
entretenir le patrimoine arboré
l'activité principale de l'entreprise
belbéoc'h située à limay elle travaille
pour des collectivités des entreprises
ou des particuliers
une fois coupé les morceaux de bois sont
récupérés et revaloriser le but c'est de
revaloriser au maximum tout ce qu'on
récolte comme matière d'avoir un minimum
de bon sens en revalorisant les déchets
de coupe pour développer la
revalorisation du bois cette société
souhaite investir près de 2 millions
d'euros c'est dans ce cadre là qu'elle a
bénéficié du fonds d'accélération des
investissements industriels dans les
territoires une subvention de cinq cent
soixante quinze mille euros du plan
france relance ça va nous permettre
d'acquérir le terrain d'un hectare qui
est derrière pour
avoir plus de place de stockage de
déchets de coupe et de
et de revalorisation c'est reproduire à
grande échelle ce qu'on fait ici sur une
petite surface qui nous limite forcément
dans la
capacité de revalorisation
[Musique]
aujourd'hui cette scierie mobile permet
de couper les grumes pour faire des
planches de bois ça servait à
revaloriser le bois donc soit on planche
en poutre enfin bois de construction
bois de menuiserie un peu tout ce qu'on
veut cet investissement permettra
d'acquérir une machine de ce type plus
performantes l'objectif est aussi de ne
plus sous traiter le broyage pour
transformer les plus gros morceaux de
bois en copeaux il ya la plaquette qui
sert au chauffage des grosses
chaufferies donc aujourd'hui ces
plaquettes elles sont issues des grumes
que l'on voit ici ici et aujourd'hui on
externalise cette prestation c'est à
dire qu'une fois tous les deux mois un
prestataire qui vient brouiller et qui
nous sort de la plaquette avec laquelle
on se chauffe et on alimente d'autres
chaufferie de la région créé en 1986
l'entreprise belbéoc'h compte 85
collaborateurs
elle réalise en moyenne un chiffre
d'affaires de 8 millions d'euros par an
avant de vous laisser nous allons faire
la connaissance d'un petit sportif il
est âgé de quatre ans son nom georges
son prénom c'est george hill a débuté le
golf a seulement en deux ans le jeune
garçon est le plus jeune licencié du
golfe isabella de plaisir est muni de
son club xs l'yvelinois vient taper la
balle chaque dimanche avec sa famille
pour traits de ce très jeune passionné
par 10 cents et magna santisteva la
caisse qui t'apprend à jouer au golf
a pas une passion de père en fils à 4
ans seulement georges est le plus jeune
licencié du golfe isabella de plaisir
une histoire avec les clubs qui a débuté
il ya presque deux ans ça faisait un an
et enfin un peu moins d'un an et six
mois qu'il avait démarré et donc il ya
eu cette période de co vide où on était
tous à la maison et là bas pendant les
après midi lorsqu'on était enfermé bas
j'ai sorti un club est vraiment j'ai
remarqué que george a été très attiré il
tapait avec moi pratiquement tous les
midis un petit des balles pour faire des
petites approche pour françois son père
georges a déjà les qualités pour faire
de lui un futur bon golfeur et ce même
en temps de pluie je trouve qu'il est et
reste très concentré parce qu'ils
apprécient vraiment ça ils sont
objectifs et quand il tape une balle
c'est nous montrer qu' il a réussi donc
les très cher lorsqu'il réussit à taper
la balle et après vraiment essayé de la
rentrée jusque dans le trou et il reste
très patient donc ça s'est vraiment bien
et c'est aussi autre chose c'est que
quand il rate un coup il arrive à se
reconcentrer dire c'est pas grave je
vais réessayer une deuxième fois tous
les dimanches l'apprenti golfeur vient
sur le domaine de plaisir soit pour
jouer avec sa famille soit pour
renforcer ses bases lors d'un cours de
45 minutes georges a été a été licencié
l'année de ses deux ans a au cours de
cette deuxième année là il a démarré à
deux ans et demi et et on a grand
plaisir à le compter parmi nos effectifs
effectivement notre plus jeune pousse et
ça prouve à tout le monde qu'il n'ya pas
ya vraiment pas de limite pour que pour
commencer le goal
contrairement à d'autres enfants du club
il a il a moins déjà besoin de ses
parents pour aller tout de suite en
cours en fait il est il espère motiver
il pas trop timide georges a déjà passé
son premier drapeau en cours et
lorsqu'on lui demande il se voit
poursuivre sa passion pour toute la vie
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant ne
manquez pas le retour de votre émission
du mardi le 7-8 culture à la barre célia
gars de son beau très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]